la première étape de parcours sup a
recueilli de janvier à mars des voeux de
19 mille candidats sur l'académie avec
une moyenne de 7 à 8 de chacun à système
en ligne assez facile d'accès c'était
assez bien expliquée en plus les profs
phare nous avait aussi expliqué au lycée
et tout donc oui c'était simple enfin
c'est clair j'attends une réponse
positive pour
la prépa économique j'ai demandé
c'est ce que je veux le plus et ça les
halles le saura la semaine prochaine le
22 ce sera oui non ou en attente d'une
place et la situation ne sera pas figé
mais en perpétuelle évolution
chaque matin ils sauront de combien de
places ils sont augmentées sur leur rôle
alors classe en attente et ils auront
aussi l'information de savoir s'ils ont
eu de nouvelles propositions
donc il ya pas deux il n'y a pas de date
limite simplement il ya un moment où les
cours vont commencer à l'université donc
la procédure s'arrête le 5 septembre
mais d'ici là tout le monde doit trouver
sa place dans d'autres cas les voeux
parcours sud viendront après un autre
choix celui d'une école qui recrutent
sur concours comme la bsb de dijon par
exemple si je suis pas prêt dans l'école
je penserai quand même par parler vrai
que j'ai fait par part pour sup mais je
suis content vraiment plus sûre sur le
l'école de gréasque que j'ai choisi que
sur parcours sur parcours sub fait le
pari de 0 bacheliers sans admission il
était encore 90000 l'été dernier si le
nouveau système y parvient il sera en
tout cas marqué par un mot qui fâche ou
qui suscite la polémique le mot
sélection l'occasion d'ailleurs de
montrer qu'il n'ya pas à ce sujet qu'une
seule et même façon de penser
les critiques sont souvent menées par
des élèves en classe prépa il y en a en
classe prépa déjà leurs arguments tient
pas debout parce que eux mêmes sont dans
des sections sélective
donc si vous voulez plus de sélections
bas il quitte la prépa il arrête tout et
puis ils font pousser des haricots
c'est vrai qu'il faut que tout le monde
ait accès à l'éducation donc si on
trouve un moyen de rendre au moins un
système d'éducation accessible à tous
c'est bien messi a plus d'autres moyens
faudra sélectionner pays tant pis ça
forcera les gens à travailler
la semaine prochaine la plupart des
candidats auront déjà une bonne idée de
ce qui les attend à la rentrée en
sachant qu'il y a toujours le même
préambule à cette histoire et c'est
encore passe ton bac d'abord